The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Ready to roll?
OK, good afternoon.
Count down four lectures
and you know everything
you have to know about
atomic and optical physics,
at least for those of you
who take part two-- for those
of you who've taken part one and
part two-- for the other ones,
well, there is one more semester
which is the following spring.
So we have discussed
light forces, first
with the optical
Bloch equations,
and then we discussed the
stimulated light force
using the dressed atom picture.
So this is sort of finishing
the presentation and derivation
of they light forces.
Today, I want to continue
to discuss for the aspects.
We've discussed dipole
traps, different ways how
we can understand why
there is a dipole potential
from the harmonic oscillator
to the dressed atom
to the refraction of
light by small spheres.
So in all cases, we realize
red detuned light traps.
Today I want to discuss
what is at work here,
electrical magnetic
forces, and then I
want to address
what several of you
have asked, where is
energy conservation?
Where does the energy go when
we cool with a stimulated force?
But this will only
take 10 minutes.
The main part of
today's lecture will
be techniques to go to
very low temperature
to ultra-low temperature.
This is sub-Doppler
cooling, sub-recoil cooling,
evaporative cooling,
and magnetic trapping
as a technique.
So this is the menu today.
Again, a feature-picked menu.
Now talking about electric
and magnetic forces,
you may think it's
a trick question,
but it's rather subtle.
All optical forces were derived
from the electric dipole
Hamiltonian D dot
E. This is what
we used as a starting
point for light forces.
So my question is, what
about the Lorentz force?
The Lorentz force comes
from the magnetic part
of the electromagnetic field.
Now, is there Lorentz
force on the atoms?
And, if yes, does it contribute
to the light forces or is
it negligibly small?
Actually, the question
I'm asking you,
I don't think it's
addressed in any textbook
and I think you can
go to conferences
and ask some of your colleagues.
You may get a wide
range of answers.
So but anyway, has anybody
of you thought about it?
What about, is there Lorentz
force on neutral atoms?
If no, you're done.
If yes, does it contribute,
is it negligible,
or is it even dominant?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
temperature
or is equivalent to
the T minus A picture,
and the T minus A picture
has the Lorentz force, so
[INAUDIBLE].
So.
PROFESSOR: So it
should be included
because we are talking about
two different representations.
Collin?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK, so yes.
The Lorentz force is included.
Also, when you ride
on D dot E, you
think it's the electric
force of an electric dipole.
We come to that in a moment.
The next question is,
do you have any idea
if the Lorentz
force is important
or whether it's negligible?
AUDIENCE: For neutral, or?
PROFESSOR: For neutral atoms.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, who of you is
working on optical lattices
or wants to work on
optical lattices?
OK, just to catch
your attention,
when the atom goes up and down
the optical lattice, if feels
the lattice potential.
The force is 100%
the Lorentz force.
There is no contribution
from the electric force.
So that's what I
want to show you now.
So we have two fundamental
forces, the electric force
and-- if you have two charges
separated in the field,
two different electric fields--
we derive from the Coulomb
force, the dipole force.
And the force on
the electric dipole
is-- that potential is-- D
dot E. The gradient of it
is D times gradient E-- with
correct Victorian notation--
whereas the Lorentz
force is V cross B.
So these are the two
forces we have to consider.
Let me show two configurations
where we use dipole forces,
the stimulated light force.
One is here where we
focus a laser beam,
and let's just assume for
the sake of the discussion
that the laser beam--
it's propagating here
and the linear polarization
goes up and down.
So now we have a dipole
moment of the atom, which
oscillates up and down, which is
parallel to the electric field.
So now we have D dot E, and
indeed if you take the atom
and move it into
the laser beam, it
will experience an
attractive force
and this attractive
force is purely electric.
But let's now come to the
situation which many of you
work on in the laboratory, would
that we have two plane waves--
so the laser beams are
infinity extended--
we have two plane waves and
they form an optical lattice.
Now, the dipole, the oscillating
dipole, the electric dipole,
is again driven by
linearly polarized light.
It points up, but the
gradient of the electric field
is in the direction of the
interference of the lattice,
so the gradient of
the electric field
is perpendicular to
the dipole moment.
So therefore, D
dot E is exactly 0,
and therefore, the electric part
of the potential-- the Coulomb
force which is
microscopically behind it--
will not contribute anything.
So I could stop here
and say, well, OK,
since we have only the Coulomb
force and the Lorentz force,
I've proven to you it's
not the Coulomb force,
so therefore it's
a Lorentz force.
But let me just tell you why.
So what I'm really telling you
is it is actually remarkable
that if you go along
the Z direction
and we take the Z derivative of
the AC Stock's shift potential,
and the AC Stock's shift
potential is one half,
alpha is now the
polarizability--
we use alpha in many
places-- times E square.
So this is the AC
Stock's shift potential,
and the spatial derivative of
the AC Stock's shift potential
is a force, but it's
the Lorentz force.
Actually, I was amazed.
I had to work it out
myself because I haven't
seen it discussed anywhere,
but you can simply
take the electric field
of a standing wave,
perform this derivative,
and what you find
is you get the Lorentz force.
If you wonder how you get
it without going through all
the Victorian notation,
the Lorentz force
is V cross B. The
velocity of the charge
is related to the derivative
of the dipole moment.
The dipole moment is
charge times position,
and the derivative
of the dipole moment
is charge times velocity.
So don't let yourself
fool yourself.
When you have an
oscillating field,
there are charges which move
their currents inside the atom.
So our V cross B, the
V is pretty much D dot.
The D dot is
polarizability times E dot,
this is alpha
polarizability-- frequency
times the electric field.
But, as Cody said, we can
go form P dot A to D dot E--
or, to be precise-- the magnetic
field is the curl of the vector
potential, and the curl
gives us the [INAUDIBLE]--
I'm suppressing Victorian
notation, here--
and you know that E,
the electric field,
is the temporal derivative of
A, so therefore we get that.
So if you now multiply D
dot with the curl of A,
you get something which
is K alpha E square.
K is for a standing wave,
the spatial derivative.
So I've shown you--
at least you can
see by dimensional analysis,
or by just pointing
to the different terms, that if
you take the AC Stock's shift
potential through
the derivative,
you get everything which you
have in the Lorentz force.
It would be a 10 minute,
easy homework assignment,
but we're running out of
homework assignments-- we're
at the end of the semester--
to show that, explicitly.
So it is really
the Lorentz force
which provides the
trapping potential
in an optical lattice.
Questions?
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: So in
the simple picture
you have [INAUDIBLE]
the lattice,
you're saying that the
transverse confinement is
provided by the
electric force, but what
about the perpendicular
direction?
[INAUDIBLE] electric field like
this, but the other direction?
PROFESSOR: OK, I can discuss
with you two simple geometries.
In one case, in
one direction it's
the pure Coulomb force at work.
In the other direction,
it's the pure Lorentz force.
But in general, when you go
through an AC Stock's shift
potential, you have both.
So you may wonder that
the Coulomb force, when
you integrate it, would
not be integrable.
It does not give
rise to potential.
Also, the Lorentz force does
not give rise to potential.
But if you add the Coulomb
force and the Lorentz force,
you can integrate it up to
the optical dipole potential.
I find it remarkable,
but it is what it is.
Questions?
So energy conservation, yes.
That's a good thing
to discuss now.
Let me first discuss I want
to have-- energy conservation
has to be discussed with
two different perspectives.
One is a transient
phenomenon-- which
I'll do in a few minutes-- but
let me first discuss something,
which is CW, and this
is the following.
You have atoms which move
over a standing wave,
and I use the dressed
atom picture to show you
that-- for a strong, blue
detuned standing wave--
we have a friction force.
So the atom-- this was
the Sisyphus cooling--
that the atom is climbing up
hills, there's some transition,
climbs up the next hill,
but on average the atom
climbs up more hills
than it scoots down,
and therefore
there is work done.
There is a net force, and this
net force provides friction.
It slows down the
velocity of the atom.
My question to you is,
where has this energy gone?
The kinetic energy lost by atom,
where does this energy appear?
Which fields?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
the laser beam?
PROFESSOR: Well, we have two
fields, the laser fields,
and we have maybe a
spontaneous emission?
But the force is only a
stimulated force due to-- yeah?
Which fields?
AUDIENCE: The laser field?
Because when you stimulate
into a laser field,
your [INAUDIBLE]
modulator [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well, I have a
little bit problem with that
because when the
atoms-- the force
comes from distributing
photons from one standing
wave to the other one, and these
are photons of equal frequency.
So in that sense, the net effect
is that those two laser beams--
actually, the atom moves, here.
So what should happen
to the laser beams?
Photons are not disappearing.
I will later tell you, in the
transient picture-- and this,
maybe you've already done your
homework assignment number 10--
there is something
happening to the laser beam.
But this would only
happen when atoms fly in
and fly out of a laser beam.
Then we have a
different situation.
But here, if the atoms stay in
the laser beam the laser beam--
so to speak-- sees a constant
index of refraction medium.
It just goes through
and nothing has
happened to the photons except
that-- occasionally-- photons
are spontaneously emitted.
Well, OK.
If it's not the laser
beams, what remains now?
AUDIENCE: Spontaneous
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Spontaneous emission.
Now how can spontaneous
emission carry the energy?
What is the spectrum of
spontaneous emission?
AUDIENCE: Triplets?
PROFESSOR: Yes,
the mono-triplet.
We have the central
carrier, the central carrier
is not carrying away
any energy because it
is at the laser frequency.
Now we have two side bands.
Can the side bands
carry away energy?
AUDIENCE: Interlacing them.
PROFESSOR: Huh?
AUDIENCE: Interlacing
with the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Asymmetry
in what sense?
AUDIENCE: If the side bands
are [INAUDIBLE] escape.
PROFESSOR: Well, but
didn't we discuss,
with a radiative cascade,
that the blue detuned side
bend comes when you go from
the upper dressed level
to the dressed level?
And in the lower
dressed level, you
can only emit a red detuned side
band, not a blue detuned side
bands.
What we said in the
radiative cascade
after one blue detuned photon,
there is a red detuned photon.
So the number of photons
emitted on the red side band
and on the blue side
band are exactly equal.
[INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: But then you have the
[INAUDIBLE] cooling picture,
where the red detuned side then
was emitted in the lower field
region?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So the situation
is the following.
The atom emits an
equal number red, blue.
Red detuned and blue detuned,
red detuned and blue detuned.
But when it emits
the blue detuned,
the side bend spacing
is larger because it
emits the blue detuned photon
when it's on top of the hill.
And the red detuned
photon is emitted
when the atom is
more in the dark,
and therefore, the side
bend spacing is lower.
So it alternates
blue, red, blue, red.
But the blue detuned photon is
emitted when the generalized RB
frequency is larger, when
the atoms is at an anti-node
And the red detuned is
more preferably emitted
when the photon is at a
node of the standing wave.
So it is the difference
of these modulations,
the side bands are modulated,
and there is a preference
to emit the blue detuned
side band when the side band
spacing is larger than
in the red detuned case.
And this is where
the energy goes.
AUDIENCE: You could make
the argument and that
would give a simple picture
for the maximum cooling rate?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Where you have omega
times your [? scattering ?]
rate?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
That's exactly how, last class,
I calculated the cooling rate.
The cooling rate, the energy
removed from the system,
is, well, yeah, I said it is
the height of the lattice,
but the height of
the lattice is also
the amount by which
the-- the lattice is
nothing else than the
generalized RB frequency.
This is the energy level
of one crest level,
and therefore the
lattice is the increment
by which we modulate
blue and red side bands.
Exactly.
This can be
quantitatively worked out.
If I had another half hour,
I could do it for you.
It's in the
references, but this is
the physical
picture for cooling.
OK, but so you realize, this
is one of the subtleties.
We can understand
the force simply
from a simple picture, energy
levels, Sisyphus cooling
and such, but in
order to understand
where the energy comes from,
we need the mono-triplet.
We need spontaneous emission.
So the force comes from the
redistribution of photons.
It's the stimulated
redistribution
of photons which is
responsible for the force,
but the energy
balance comes from,
what can be neglected for
the momentum balance, namely
the few spontaneous emission
events, and especially
those which involve the
blue and red side bands.
And it beautifully
works together
and all the equation
of physics are obeyed.
OK, but that tells you now
that the cooling effect
hinges on spontaneous emission.
And yes, spontaneous
emission is dissipation.
And whenever you want the
friction coefficient--
you want dissipation--
you need an open system
and the open system is
spontaneous emission
into those nodes.
So let's now talk about
an opposite situation
where we do not have any
spontaneous emission.
And I think almost
all the people
who work with optical lattices
use infrared lasers for them,
or [INAUDIBLE] detuned laser
where spontaneous emission
happens only once
every 20, 30 seconds
or 100 seconds per atom, so
we can really neglect it.
So now the question
is the following.
Assume you have a
focused laser beam
and you load a
Bose-Einstein condensate
at the edge of the cloud,
and now the condensate
is accelerated, sucked
into the laser beam.
So now the atom
has kinetic energy.
The question is, where does
this kinetic energy come from?
And this time, we do not
have spontaneous emission
as we have when we do
frictional cooling.
So the question is now, where
does the energy of the atom
come from?
AUDIENCE: But if we were talking
about a dielectric medium,
it's coming from those light
waves that are reflected or not
reflected.
PROFESSOR: If comes
from those light rays,
but-- the atom is a dielectric
medium, that's good--
but the reflection and
deflection of light rays--
at least in leading order-- you
would say photons of the same
energy are deflected--
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't the
[INAUDIBLE] of the atom
just get absorbed [INAUDIBLE]
and the [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: I would hate to
use the picture of absorption
and emission.
What really happens is
it's just scattering.
It's scattering.
you scatter a photon
which has one frequency
into a different direction.
It's really light scattering.
Well, you have a homework
assignment on that,
and I don't need to go into
details because it can easily
be worked out, but what
happens is the following.
The atom is a dielectric medium.
It has an index of refraction.
And if you put an
index-- if you suddenly
put an index of refraction
into a laser beam--
then you change the
phase of the laser beam.
The atoms act as an
electro-optical modulator,
and they change the frequency
of the transmitted photons.
You have a homework
assignment on that.
So if you increase the number
of atoms in your laser beam,
because they move in,
this is-- the phase
of the transmitted
photons is shifted.
If the phase of the photons is
shifted during a certain time,
phase over time is frequency.
So therefore you will see,
when the atoms move in and gain
kinetic energy, the transmitted
photons of the laser beam
have lost some energy.
They are slightly
shifted to the red.
So in other words, it's funny
but if you have a dipole trap
and the laser beam
is focused and atoms
slosh through the trap,
if you would carefully
analyze the frequency
of the transmitted beam,
you will find that it's a
little bit blue, a little bit
red, a little bit
blue, a little bit
red, and this compensates
for the kinetic energy.
Again, I don't think you'll
find it in any textbook.
It confused me for a while
until I could work it out.
But the homework assignment
gives you an exact dissoluble
model where you can exactly
show what I told you.
So these are the two
situations, here.
It's either
spontaneous emission,
which is responsible
for cooling,
but here we have a
conservative potential.
And in this
conservative potential,
the only player is the laser
beam which is transmitted.
And, indeed, it is the photons
which have been transmitted,
and usually you wouldn't
put that into your picture.
Remember, the dipole
force can be explained
by eliminating the
coherent field of the laser
field-- for canonical
transformation--
and then we have a C number.
We have a classical
electric field.
This is your Hamiltonian,
and from this Hamiltonian,
you derive that you have
a conservative potential.
But if you now ask
where the energy goes,
the energy-- really,
in this situation--
goes into a frequency
shift of the photons.
Also, in your
Hamiltonian, you have
assumed that the electric field
is an external classical field,
E naught times cosine omega T.
Well, if you want
my advice, whenever
you use the AC Stock's
shift for trapping,
just use the AC Stock's
shift and regard it
as a classic potential,
and just completely forget
that there are photons behind
because if you want to account
what really happens to the
photons-- what really happens
to the energy in this
system-- it really gets ugly
and it can get really confusing.
Questions?
OK, we are done with
the stimulated force.
We are now in
preparation for next week
when I want to tell you
about degenerate Fermi gases
and degenerate Bose gases.
Those gases require
nanokelvin temperatures,
so today, in the
next hour, I want
to tell you what
are the techniques
to create such
ultra-low temperatures,
and the techniques
I want to discuss
is one addition
to laser cooling.
We have so far discussed laser
cooling to the Doppler limit,
but now I have to tell
you that that's not
where laser cooling stops.
You can go sub-Doppler
and sub-recoil.
And, at least when
the Nobel Prize
was given to Bill Phillips,
Steve Chu, and Claude
Cohen-Tannoudji, well, if
you go to the Nobel website
and read the report of the
Nobel Committee-- well,
they should have given
it to those three
people for the many,
many wonderful things
they have done, and I've
made frequent references
to their work.
Bill Phillips invented
Zeeman slower,
Claude Cohen-Tannoudji invented
the dressed atom picture,
they have many,
many contributions,
but the Nobel Committee
tried to justify their choice
with a coherent story,
and the coherent story
was Steve Chu cooled to the
Doppler limit in molasses,
Bill Phillips discovered
sub-Doppler cooling,
and Claude Cohen-Tannoudji
realized sub-recoil cooling.
So the storyline was
cold, colder, the coldest.
And that's what we
want to talk today.
So sub-Doppler cooling.
Well, I could have spent--
or, 10 years ago, I
spent a whole lecture
on sub-Doppler cooling,
polarization gradient cooling.
Wonderful!
The kind of epiphany of
elegance in [INAUDIBLE]
a mechanical
description of an atom.
But I have to say--
and then I explained,
in another lecture,
sub-recoil cooling,
how you can even cool
below the recoil limit.
Well, this year, 2013,
I spent 15 minute on it.
The reason is the following.
When I joined atomic
physics and was a post-doc
in the '90s and
assistant professor,
the conference's
[INAUDIBLE] of [INAUDIBLE],
[INAUDIBLE] was full on intents
to find new ways to laser cool.
Ideas of how to get to lower
and lower temperatures.
There were many, many
different-- sub-Doppler,
sub-recoil techniques
were discussed.
This was the main topic.
But then suddenly,
in 1995, evaporative
cooling-- an intellectually
boring cooling technique,
just have atoms
collide and evaporate--
this led to the lowest
temperature ever,
and it was almost a
sudden transition.
Within a few months there was
no research, no papers anymore,
on advanced methods
of laser cooling.
Evaporative cooling it
just completely wiped out
this area over atomic physics.
The reason being because
all cooling schemes which
have been discussed had,
in the end, some problems.
At some point, photons heat.
Heat because they excite an atom
and if an excited atom collides
with another atom, there is
a heating mechanism and such.
So even all the optimistic
proposals for laser cooling
reached very low temperature,
but never at high density.
And evaporative cooling
just did everything for you.
But anyway, I think it-- not
just because a Nobel Prize was
given for sub-Doppler
and sub-recoil cooling,
this is really an accomplishment
to understand how can you
go through conventional
cooling limits,
and at least every
graduate student
who happens to graduate
in AMO physics at MIT
should know what
are the concepts
behind sub-Doppler and
sub-recoil cooling.
So what I need in order to
introduce those cooling methods
for you is I have to remind
you that optical pumping is
a cooling scheme, and one could
actually say, to some extent,
every cooling you do with lasers
is based on optical pumping.
And so let me explain that.
Optical pumping
happens that-- let's
say you have a level
structure with a circularly
polarized light where you can
go maybe from M equals 1 to M
equals zero.
And then there can be
spontaneous emission back to M
equals 1 and back to M equals
minus 1, but the laser--
because it has
angular momentum--
cannot excite this state
to any excited state.
So what happens is, of
course, pretty clear.
You have whatever distribution
you have in state one and two.
You switch on your laser,
and after a few cycles
everything has fallen
into the dark state.
You have 100%
population in stage two.
So this is the simplest
example of optical
pumping using the
three-level scheme.
Well, you may ask now, what
has that to do with cooling?
Well, temperature is
a Boltzmann factor,
and if you-- we can define
a temperature by saying
the population
between two levels
is given by a Boltzmann factor.
Let's just introduce an
energy-splitting delta
E-- which is somewhat arbitrary
here-- but in any event,
you see if you completely
pump out a level,
if you have all the
population in one state,
this corresponds to
zero temperature.
So if you optically pump
the atoms, preferentially,
into certain states,
you have lowered
the entropy of the system, the
atoms are no longer distributed
over as many states
as before, and this
corresponds to
lower temperature.
And the message I
want to give you
is that you can understand
laser cooling as optical pumping
in translation space
in velocity space.
When you laser cool, you excite
the atoms at high velocity
and then because of the
mechanisms we discussed,
spontaneous emission
leads to lower velocities,
and this is one form
of optical pumping.
I also like the word-- optical
pumping is, in some sense,
a spontaneous Raman process.
You go up with one
photon, you go down
with-- you go up with
the laser photon,
you go down with the
spontaneously emitted photon.
So this is a spontaneous
Raman process,
and laser cooling-- even if
you have just a single ground
state-- can be regarded
as a Raman process
where the initial and
final state differ
in velocity or momentum.
You have the same
internal state,
but you have a different
external state.
So you can see laser cooling
is spontaneous Raman scattering
between different
momentum states.
OK, now how can we achieve
sub-Doppler cooling?
Sub-Doppler cooling
was discovered in 1988,
and I remember I was at the
[? IKA ?] Conference in Paris
when Bill Phillips'
group said, we've
carefully measured
the temperature
and in sodium we measure
a temperature which
is lower than the Doppler limit,
which was rigorously derived.
I derived for you the
Doppler limit of molasses.
So what went wrong here?
Well, it became clear
the only loophole--
if you have a theory
which predicts something
and then you find a
violation, you carefully
have to check the assumption.
And the assumption
which was made--
and which we have
made in this course--
is that you had a
two-level system.
Now, atoms have
hyperfine structure--
and for pedagogical
reasons, because I
want to explain to you why
in sub-Doppler cooling scheme
I assume this hyperfine
structure with F
equals one half, F
equals three half--
but let me first tell you
what the novel feature is
about a multi-level atom
which has hyperfine structure.
Now, the one thing
which happens is
that-- instead of just going
between our single ground state
and our single excited state--
we now have transitions.
You may want to call
them Raman transitions,
or optical pumping, between
the hyperfine atoms.
So there are now transitions
not only up to an excited
state which rapidly
decays, there
are now transitions--
Raman transitions--
between ground states which
have a very low widths.
The width of the
excited state is gamma.
Well, what is the width
of the ground state?
Well, if you don't
have a laser beam,
the width is zero,
but if you have
laser beams the atom
doesn't stay there forever.
There will be a time, which
is estimated here-- depending
on the RB frequency and the
detuning-- this is the time,
this is simply nothing
else than the scattering
rate which we derived before.
So that's the rate at
which you scatter photons.
And then, depending what
the bunching ratio is,
this is also the time in
which you may optically
pump to another ground state.
So therefore, what we
have to take into account
now is that we have narrower
widths in our system,
and those widths correspond to
another two-level system which
is driven by two photons in
which connects the two ground
states.
I will not give you any
derivation how this exactly
leads to a lower
temperature, but I
want to give you two
pictures which I have already
introduced to you.
One is, remember, when we
discussed Doppler cooling,
the final temperature was
proportionate to gamma,
the width of the transition.
So now I wave my hands and
say, if you have transitions
between ground states which have
a much, much smaller width--
which is the rate
of optical pumping--
and for low laser
power this width
can become very, very narrow.
But you have at
least one ingredient
which can lead to a
lower temperature.
OK, in all truth in
advertising, for the Sisyphus--
for the polarization
gradient cooling scheme--
the final temperature
is not given
by gamma prime, the
rate of optical pumping.
It is a proportionality factor,
but there is another factor.
If you want to
learn about it, you
have to read some of
the classic papers.
But there is another
picture which I can also
use to tell you--
and that's actually
related-- why optical
pumping at least gives
the possibility for
lower temperature.
I explained to you with the
stimulated force in [? blue ?]
molasses-- that the only
reason why we have cooling--
is that the atom has a lag time.
It cannot instantaneously adjust
itself to the light field.
It lags behind.
And you can say,
in Doppler cooling,
the lag time is the
spontaneous emission time,
and the inverse of it is gamma.
Here, in this case,
the lag time can
be the very long time
to optically pump.
So therefore, if the atom is
in one hyperfine state and now
moves into an area where the
polarization of the laser beams
is different, it may take
a long time to adjust.
And it is this lag time to
which the friction coefficient
was proportional.
So this is a new feature, long
delay times, narrow widths,
and resonances between
ground state levels.
OK, a little bit
show and tell now.
Nobody thought
about polarization
creating cooling, nobody
thought about Doppler cooling,
but it was discovered
when people simply
did Doppler molasses
and it's one
of those big violations
of Murphy's law
where cooling worked much better
than everybody had thought,
and the result is the following.
That-- when I drew for
you the blue curve, which
is force versus velocity--
it's pretty much
the subtraction of
two [? Lorentzian ?].
What happened is-- for sodium
atoms, or for any alkali atom--
it's the red curve.
For large velocity you have
the Doppler cooling mechanism,
but for smaller velocities you
have a steepening of the slope,
and the steeper the slope,
the larger is your friction
coefficient, alpha.
And this is the mechanism of
polarization gradient cooling.
Let me just take
this famous paper
and show you one way how
polarization gradient cooling
works, which is the most famous
form of sub-Doppler cooling,
and this goes as follows.
If you have molasses
with two laser beams
and the two laser
beams are lin-perp-lin,
linear polarization
perpendicular
to the other linear
polarization.
So you have two laser beams
with these polarization.
When these two polarizations
overlap and they
have the same phase, you
get light at 45 degree,
but if these two polarization
have 90 degree out of phase,
you get circularly
polarized light.
So as these two laser
beams counter-propagate,
you periodically go from
linear polarized sigma minus,
linear polarized sigma plus.
So you have spatial--
at any given point
you have a polarization, but
the polarization changes.
You have a-- you
would say, naively,
lin-perp-lin don't interfere,
don't form a standing wave.
Well, they do not form a
standing wave in intensity.
They form a standing
wave in polarization.
So now what happens
is the following.
If you have a multi-level atom
and I use this simple scheme
here, the different
polarizations,
linear polarization
drives, the pi transition,
sigma plus and sigma
minus [INAUDIBLE]
different transitions,
and those transitions
have different strengths.
So an atom here--
when it experience
this polarization--
reaches cycle,
but when it experiences the
other circular polarization,
it will be optically pumped
over here and then it cycles.
So therefore, an atom which from
sigma plus polarization and was
here, it flies over to
an area where you've
sigma minus polarization, it
will actually be pumped over.
So the atom will constantly
be pumped back and forth
between those hyperfine states.
And this actually gives rise
to a beautiful form of Sisyphus
cooling that the atom
experiences sigma plus
light in one ground state.
It climbs up the hill, it
sees the AC Stock's shift
potential-- and the AC
Stock's shift potential,
because of the, for instance,
for one hyperfine state, sigma
plus drives the
strongest transition--
and therefore we have
sigma plus light,
one ground state has
the deepest potential.
Where we have sigma
minus light, it
is the other ground state which
has the deepest potential.
And so what happens is that the
atom is in one hyperfine state.
It climbs up the
hill, and then it's
optically pumped to the
other hyperfine state,
and we have exactly the same
kind of Sisyphus cooling.
I just show you pictures
and you sort of match it
with what you know.
This is more
complicated because this
involves optical pumping
between hyperfine states.
The different hyperfine states
have different [INAUDIBLE]
coefficients and such.
It's not really complicated
but more complex.
What I explained to you
is how Sisyphus cooling
works in the
dressed atom picture
just for a two-level system.
And here you find a more subtle
form of Sisyphus cooling,
but this form is more
important because whenever
you operate a
magneto-optic trap,
you get this cooling
mechanism for free.
OK, so that's all I want to tell
you about sub-Doppler cooling.
OK, sub-recoil cooling, we
can quickly deal with it
because I want to prove to you
here that sub-recoil cooling is
impossible.
And unless you tell me what
this wrong in my derivation,
I don't need to discuss
sub-recoil cooling
because I've convinced
you that it's impossible .
OK, so let's assume our atom
has an initial kinetic energy
and then we absorb one photon.
That would mean the momentum has
now changed by the laser photon
by the recoil-- and
then it emits a photon,
so the momentum gets reduced
by the immediate photon--
and all I do is I ask,
what is the difference
between the initial
kinetic energy
and the final kinetic energy
after two photons-- a laser
photon and the spontaneously
photon-- have been exchanged?
And what you find is--
and this is just exact--
that the change in energy is
two times the recoil energy.
The recoil energy is h-bar
square K square over 2m, plus--
and this is now the
cross-term-- plus KL--
the K vector of the laser--
minus K spontaneous emission
times the velocity.
And now, of course, we
assume-- which is correct--
that spontaneous emission goes
randomly in all directions.
Therefore, if we average
over many cycles,
this does not contribute.
So therefore we find now that
the average energy exchanged
by an absorption and
emission event is two times
the recoil energy plus h-bar
K laser times [? width ?],
and we want to make it negative
because we want to cool.
Well, we make it negative by
arranging the laser beam--
surprise, surprise--
counter-propagating
to the velocity.
This is how we can
get the best cooling.
Well, surprise, that's
what we expected.
But you find, of course, that
when this velocity is a very
small then K V is
smaller than K squared.
So therefore, once the velocity
is smaller than the recoil
velocity of a single
photon, you cannot choose--
you cannot make this equation
or this expression go negative.
In other words, what
I've shown to you
is if there is an atom which
has a velocity which is smaller
than the recoil velocity
of a photon, whenever
this atom scatters
a single photon,
it will be hotter
than it was before.
So is it clear, what I've
shown you, in energy?
When an atom has
a velocity which
is smaller than the
recoil velocity,
any further photon
scattering will not cool.
It will lead to an
energy transfer delta
E, which is large,
which is possible.
So that shows you that
sub-recoil cooling
is impossible.
Any idea how we can
sub-recoil cool?
Any idea why Claude
Cohen-Tannoudji
got the Nobel Prize?
AUDIENCE: Further
down in the lattice,
you can have an
effective mass that
is much heavier than
[? bare ?] mass?
PROFESSOR: OK, great idea.
We put the atom in a lattice,
a lattice has band structure,
in a band structure we
have an effective mass,
and heavier atoms can be cooled
to lower and lower temperature.
Actually, it's well known
that, in Doppler cooling
and sub-Doppler
cooling-- especially
in sub-Doppler cooling--
cesium an rubidium reach
a microkelvin, sodium
reaches only 25 microkelvin.
So making the atom
heavier is OK,
but I have to say you're only
rescaling your recoil limit,
you're not breaking through
the recoil limit which is now
defined with a heavier
effective mass.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
emission direction--
PROFESSOR: Yes?
AUDIENCE: --means
that the atom must
have [INAUDIBLE]
responding is [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: That
was the assumption.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] at
least for this cooling,
it needs the time much larger
than the Doppler cooling
[INAUDIBLE] spontaneous
emission time?
PROFESSOR: Well, that
was the assumption here.
We scatter several times, a
spontaneously emitted photon
do not contribute the recoil
of the spontaneously emitted
photons cancels out because
spontaneous emission-- and this
is correct, this is not wrong--
spontaneous emission goes
equally probable in the plus
X and the minus X direction.
Well, I thought I want to
show you a demonstration how--
mechanical demonstration--
how you can sub-recoil cool.
It's not a demonstration
in velocity space,
it's a demonstration
in position space.
What I have here
is a Plexiglas tray
and it has a little
hole in the middle.
And I have a bunch
of ball bearings
and I put those
ball bearings in.
Let me translate.
I can blindfold myself and
all I do is I shake the tray.
So whenever I shake
it, I kick the atoms
randomly in position
space from here to here.
So the amount of position
control I have over the atoms
is on the order of this size.
But the question is,
can I-- without having
any control of the transfer
of position I give to them--
can I steer all the
atoms into an area
here into the hole in the
middle, which is very, very
narrow in position space?
So the translation is, if
I randomly scatter photons
and they kick the atoms
around with h-bar K,
I don't have any
control about momentum
transfer smaller
than h-bar K, is it
possible to localize the
atoms in momentum space
to a momentum around
zero, which is
much, much smaller than h-bar K?
Well, let's do the experiment.
I just close my eyes and I
shake it, and I shake it,
and I just shake it for a while
and I continue shaking it.
And, well, zero temperature!
So without controlling
the motion on the scale
I'm interested in, I manage to
cool into a target region which
is much, much narrower.
So in other words, what
you need is-- all you
need is-- you need
some dark state which
is velocity selective.
If you scatter light but
you create a situation where
once the atoms are close to zero
velocity, they're not excited.
You're not steering the
atoms in a deterministic way,
you just wait until-- by random
chance-- one photon is emitted,
and by the random chance
the atom hits the hole.
And then, it will never
be re-excited again.
This was the idea of
this demonstration.
And I could, yes,
in the old days
I may have spent two
hours on teaching it,
but by using Raman resonances
between ground states--
which are terribly narrow--
or by using VSCPT-- velocity
selective coherent population
trapping-- you can create
such narrow dark
resonances which
have the effect that the atoms
scatter, scatter, scatter,
but the moment they reach a
very narrow region around zero
velocity, they stop scattering.
So what was wrong in my
proof is that here we
have a situation where we
stop the laser cooling exactly
at the time when the
atom, by random chance,
happens to be at low velocity,
at very low velocity.
And then you don't
need any control,
you just accumulate
in the same way
as I accumulated
the ball bearings.
OK, this was sub-recoil cooling
in five minutes. [? Timo ?]?
AUDIENCE: So I wasn't
here last class.
But just to summarize,
the Doppler cooling rate
gets us to a
temperature on the order
of gamma, which is
natural alignment.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And the recoil
limit is the recoil energy
which is usually
tens of kilograms.
But if you have a really,
really narrow line,
would you use the
Doppler cooling limit?
You could, in principle,
beat the recoil limit
with Doppler cooling, no?
If you have a--
PROFESSOR: No, you can't,
because if you do Doppler
cooling-- [? Timo's ?]
question is,
if you simply do molasses
with a very, very narrow line,
we derived that the limit of
Doppler cooling is Kt equals
gamma, and what
you are saying now,
if you use narrower
and narrower lines,
can we reach [? arbitrary ?]
low temperature?
This is not the case.
In our derivation
of Doppler cooling,
we made a continuum
assumptions when
we plotted the force
versus velocity
and we had the
friction force, we
assumed that an atom,
when it scatters a photon,
stays, let's say,
within the linear part
of the force versus velocity.
So we had a hidden
assumption which
required that the recoil energy
is smaller than h-bar gamma.
But there is a lot of literature
where people looked into it,
and it turns out that when
you have a very narrow line,
you can go to the recoil
limit, but you can't go beyond.
If you want to go-- and I
think this is what I showed you
in the last five
minutes-- if you want
to go below the
recoil limit, you
need some velocity-selective
dark state,
and you would not have
that in this situation.
On the other hand, if you
have a very narrow resonance,
you can probably
engineer a dark state
that there is destructive
interference in some excitation
in a very, very
narrow velocity class,
and this narrow
velocity class is simply
selected by the Doppler effect.
So you can use the narrow line
to engineer sub-recoil cooling,
but the simple arrangement
of just having molasses
with narrower and narrower
line will not work.
[? Collin ?]?
AUDIENCE: I think
the group that laser
cooled to BEC just had-- their
dark state was just a Stock's
shift, [INAUDIBLE] and that
was their-- and it shook.
There were resonances in
kilohertz or something.
PROFESSOR: Thy used
a very-- did they
go below the recoil
limit in laser cooling?
I'm not sure.
They may have had
a situation where
it was enough to go
to the recoil limit.
I have to check out
the paper, but--
AUDIENCE: I remember they did
have some sort of dark state.
Maybe it was to increase
density or-- they had the high--
PROFESSOR: Anyway,
let me just be clear.
Sub-recoil cooling
requires that you
have a dark region
in velocity space.
For that, you need some
narrow line widths.
That's necessary.
But I think you
just don't get it
by having counter-propagating
laser beams,
you have to do something more.
Other question?
OK, so I've told you
about sub-Doppler cooling,
sub-recoil cooling, but what
really got atomic physicists
to nanokelvin temperature
were two other techniques.
Laser cooling was
used as pre-cooling,
but then the final
trapping and cooling
was done by magnetic trapping
and evaporative cooling.
So I want to give you
now, in the last half
hour, a quick overview
of magnetic trapping
and evaporative cooling.
So I think any discussions
of magnetic trapping starts
with a theorem, a
theorem which tells you
that not everything is
possible you would like to do.
And this is the following, then
if you have a region without
charges and currents without--
through an empty space,
and what this theorem
says-- in empty space,
you cannot have
a local minimum--
you cannot have a local maximum
of your electric and magnetic
fields.
So if you take the strengths
of the electric field
or the strengths of
the magnetic field,
you cannot have a maximum.
You can only have a minimum.
Well, and this is important
when it comes to magnetic traps.
Depending on the magnetic
moment-- spin up,
spin down-- we could
create a trapping potential
around a maximum of
the magnetic field
or the trapping potential
around the minimum
of the magnetic field.
You want to be at the
minimum of the potential,
but if you have
a minus sign, you
may want to be at the
maximum of a magnetic field.
But [? Bing's ?] theorem
says that only one of them
is possible.
The proof really
goes in two lines.
You really show, if you assume
that there is a maximum, that
would mean that if you add a
field to it, you add a field--
and no matter in which
direction you add a field--
the total field
strengths become smaller.
But that requires a violation
of the Laplace equation.
It's easier for you-- you can
probably read it at home--
but you simply assume
you have this situation,
so you add-- and you show you
have an incremental field,
delta E. This
field, delta E, you
are at the maximum
of an electric field,
and then delta E over R
is the small difference
of the electric field.
And you can show that this
expression is only negative.
That means you have a maximum
of the electric field when
the electric field would not
fulfill the Laplace equation.
So the gist of the
argument is the following.
Each component of the
electric and magnetic field
fulfills the Laplace equation.
And the Laplace equation-- I
don't know if you've probably
heard about it-- if something
fulfills the Laplace equation,
it says at any given
point the function which
fulfills the Laplace equation
is equal to the average
of function, averaged over
a small sphere around it.
And that means-- if something
fulfills the Laplace equation--
you cannot have a local
maximum or a local minimum
because if the value
here equals the average,
that would mean in one
direction the value gets higher,
in the other direction
the value gets lower.
So if something fulfills
the Laplace equation,
you cannot have a local
maximum or local minimum.
But now, we're not asking
for maximum or minimum
in one component of the
electric or magnetic field.
We ask for a maximum or
minimum in the total value,
or the square of
the electric field.
But then you show, when you
assume that you have a maximum,
the field points
along the Z direction,
that then the Z component
of the field cannot fulfill
the Laplace equation.
So maxima are not possible.
Minima are possible.
Good!
So the magnetic
trapping potential
comes because we have a
magnetic dipole moment which
interacts with a magnetic field.
Magnetic traps are
actually classical.
You can have a classical
model for a magnetic trap,
and in that case, you
say this potentially
is mu times B
times cosine theta.
[? Crendo ?] mechanically, of
course, the angle cosine theta
is quantized and we have
the different M F levels,
the different
orientations of the spin,
relative to the Z-axis.
OK, the fact that the
magnetic field can only
have minima and not
maxima means that we
want to make sure that the
magnetic moment times the G
factor times M F is
negative, or cosine theta
is negative in the
classical picture.
And if we absorb whatever
we choose for cosine theta--
or what we call mu Bohr G
M F, the magnetic moment--
we want that the magnetic
moment of the particle
is anti-parallel to
the magnetic field.
Then we have a magnetic
trapping potential,
which is-- I've taken care
of the sin now-- mu times B,
and if B has a minimum this
potential has a minimum,
and that is a magnetic trap.
But so the consequence
of [? Bing's ?] theorem
is that we can
only trap particles
which are anti-parallel
with a magnetic field.
And they can always
lower their energy
by flipping to the other state.
So therefore, a
magnetic trap does not
allow us to trap particles
in the absolute ground state.
There is always the possibility
of spin-flip collisions
which lead to an
anti-trap state which
is expelled from
the trapping region.
Now, spin-flip
collisions can happen
when you have particles at
sufficiently high density
and they collide.
For the experts, there
can be spin relaxation,
there can be dipolar
relaxation, they
are two different kinds
of spin-flip collisions.
Fortunately, in magnetic
traps, they only
become relevant when you
pick the wrong spin state.
But for suitable
choices, magnetic traps
are very long-lived.
Dipolar relaxation is often--
can be a limiting process
for Bose-Einstein
condensates, for instance,
for high [? dose ?]
Bose-Einstein condensation,
dipolar relaxation was-- limited
the number and density of atoms
in the Bose-Einstein condensate.
But I don't want to talk
about cold collisions, here.
You should just know, based
on the fundamental theorem,
you cannot trap in
the ground state.
You have to trap
into a state which
has more energy than other
states, and, in principle,
it's possible to flip the
spin and go to a lower state.
Now, what we have
assumed here is--
when I wrote the trapping
potential like this--
I assumed that the atom stays
in a given hyperfine state.
So we put the atom in one state
and it experiences potential.
Classically it means that
the angle of the dipole,
with respect to the magnetic
field, stays constant.
And this is the case
due to rapid precession.
Classically, the
magnetic dipole precesses
around the magnetic
field, and when
the direction of the
magnetic field changes,
the rapid precession
keeps the dipole aligned.
Or, in other words, for slow
changes of the magnetic field
direction, cosine theta
is an adiabatic invariant.
So the word adiabatic is
important, either classically
or you stay in a quantum state
as long as you're adiabatic.
Well if an atom would
rapidly go through a region
of very weak magnetic
field, then the precession--
the [INAUDIBLE] precession--
of the atom is very slow,
and this adiabatic
condition can be violated.
And this violation of an
adiabaticity condition
is called Majorana flops.
So if you operate
a magnetic trap
at very low magnetic field,
you may destabilized the trap
because you violate
adiabaticity.
OK, so these are the
consequences of the fact that
we cannot create maxima,
we can only create minima
of the magnetic
field in free space,
and therefore we have to deal
with those two possible loss
processes, but we have learned
what kind of magnetic trap,
what kind of atom to pick, and
in general these are not big
problems.
OK, so we have to--
so this shows here
the typical hyperfine
structure of an alkali atom.
It could be rubidium
87 or sodium 23.
The fact that we have
only a local minimum
of the magnetic field means
we can only trap hyperfine
states-- which I've marked here
in green-- where the slope is
positive, and these
are the atoms where
the magnetic moment
is inter-parallel
with the magnetic field.
And, well, for
stability reasons we
usually pick the highest
state of the lower manifold,
or the highest state
of the upper manifold.
In principle, it would
be also possible to trap
here-- you have
the correct slope--
but often those
states suffer form
spin relaxation
and collision loss.
[? Mickey ?]?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the
picture you showed before,
is it actually possible to
make a magnetic trap with state
number four from the top so
that they expel from the center?
From [INAUDIBLE] a--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, there
is a peculiarity here,
you have the transition from the
weak field to the strong field
region.
Whenever the magnetic
moment is constant,
you need a local minimum
of the magnetic field.
But if the magnetic
moment would change
and you have a gradient
of the magnetic field,
you could actually trap here.
So in this case, you have
a magnetic field gradient
but you have a spatial variation
of the magnetic moment.
This has been discussed
in one special paper
in the literature,
but it has not really
found any [? lucent ?]
realization.
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't it
help to put the Majorana
flops in the center?
Because they're repelled
from the center.
PROFESSOR: Well,
yeah, but these atoms
would undergo
spin-flip collisions
so it's not a good choice.
It would help against
Majorana flops,
but we have many solutions
against Majorana flops.
And here, you would solve
the Majorana flops problem
but you would solve it
with another problem.
OK, so we need minima
of the magnetic field.
This provides magnetic
trapping potential,
and there are two kinds of
possible trap configuration.
One is where the minima
is at zero magnetic field,
and one is where the minima
is at finite magnetic field.
Now, the zero magnetic
field minimum one
can be simply created
with anti-Helmholtz coil.
What happens is
the magnetic field,
as a function of position, would
actually cross through zero.
It's just a field gradient
which crosses through zero,
but, of course, since
we are interested
in the absolute value
of the magnetic field,
we get the V-shape potential.
This V-shape
potential was what was
used for the first demonstration
for Bose-Einstein condensation
because a V-shape potential
is much, much more
confining in this cusp than in
harmonic oscillator potential.
And this had advantages
for tight confinement
and rapid evaporative cooling.
So those quadrupoled traps
with the V-shape potential
are the best
confinement you can get,
the best confinement
for the buck,
and the buck here is your
power supply and your coils.
However, they have
a problem when
the magnetic field is zero.
We violate adiabaticity
because the different spin
configurations
become degenerate,
and in degenerates you
can't have adiabaticity.
So therefore, the two
first demonstrations
of Bose-Einstein condensation
avoided this cusp
in two different ways.
One way was to use a
rotating magnetic field,
and to use a perpendicular field
but which was time-dependent,
and the MIT solution was to
use a blue detuned laser beam,
use the optical dipole trap--
optical dipole potential--
to push the atoms away from
the dangerous [INAUDIBLE]
field region.
I should say rotating-- none
of those-- most traps which
are now used are the other
kind of trap, the trap which
has an harmonic oscillator
potential, which doesn't have
the cusp and where the minimum
is at a finite magnetic field.
Let me just make one comment.
The rotating trap
was very popular
because it led to the first BEC
and a lot of people built that,
but to the best of
my knowledge, it's
only used in different places.
And the only real
application it has
is-- since you have some
rotating magnetic field--
by some modification
you can actually
make of rotating potential.
And this is nice if
you want to study
Bose-Einstein condensation
on a rotating frame,
create vortices and
things like that.
But for simply creating a
Bose-Einstein condensate,
this trap is used, by
far, most frequently.
But there is actually a
renaissance of this trap.
One reason why
people use this trap
and why my own research
group immediately
switched to this
trap-- and we had
the idea how to built it--
is, well, harmonic potential
is nice.
Every physicist loves
an harmonic potential.
You can solve,
immediately, thermodynamics
in a harmonic potential.
Who wants to deal
with that potential?
Also, if the laser beam
just drifts by a micrometer,
this symmetric potential
becomes asymmetric.
So you characterize
your potential today
and a few hours later you
have a different potential.
Whereas a magnetic potential,
harmonic potential,
once it's characterized--
as long as you don't change
the current in your
power supplies--
it's the same week after
week, months after months.
Well, there is a renaissance
now because a lot of groups
now doing experiments
in optical lattices,
they don't care what shape the
potential is because they don't
do physics in this potential.
They just take the Bose-Einstein
condensate or the cooled Fermi
gases and transfer them
to an optical lattice.
So in that case, it
doesn't play any role,
and then the advantage
of this potential
is you get more
bang for the buck.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] you were
saying before [INAUDIBLE] more
rapid evaporation in V-shape
versus the [INAUDIBLE].
Where is the differences
in evap time?
PROFESSOR: It depends.
I may run out of time today.
I needed-- I can
probably-- I wanted
to go through
evaporative cooling,
and I will talk to you that,
for evaporative cooling,
there could be a
threshold in confinement
where you go into
a runaway regime
that evaporative
cooling is speeding up.
So a little bit of confinement
can make the difference
without never getting
into a runaway regime
or being in that runaway regime.
So confinement,
extra confinement,
can make the difference
between getting BEC and not
getting a BEC.
So it really depends.
It's highly nonlinear,
but I will show you
later on that when you
put a system together,
the kind of threshold density
at which the cloud can evaporate
to BEC is much lower
here than it is there.
But-- and this is
the next thing I
want to explain--
it's not really
that this is a linear potential
and this is a [INAUDIBLE]
potential because those
finite magnetic field--
these traps which have a minimum
at a finite magnetic field--
are usually done in
the following way.
Those traps are called
Ioffe-Pritchard trap.
Ioffe actually suggested such
a magnetic field configuration
for confinement of
plasma, and Dave Pritchard
was the first to point out
that such a configuration would
be a good choice
for neutral atoms.
So I sometimes joke and I
say, well, plasma physics
is the study of very hot matter.
Cold atoms is the study
of very cold matter.
But when matter is either too
hot or too cold that you cannot
put it in ordinary container,
you want it confined with
magnetic fields.
And it happens that,
for plasma, you
need a minimum of the magnetic
field, and for neutral atoms
you need a minimum of
the magnetic field.
So therefore here is something
which ultra-cold atoms have
in common with plasma physics.
I don't think there is a lot
the two fields have in common,
but when it comes to magnetic
field configurations, yes.
A similar magnetic
field configuration
can confine a plasma and
can confine neutral atoms.
OK, so the generic way of
how these magnetic fields are
generated is you want to have
two coils, called pinch coils.
You can say each of them creates
a magnetic field which decays,
a magnetic field which
decays, and now in the middle
you have the parabolic minimum.
But then you have to add the
so-called four Ioffe bars which
create a linear potential,
and this is shown here.
So the pinch coil is simply
creating a local minimum
along the Z-axis,
and if you only
want to trap in one
dimension, you would be done,
But you want to trap
in 3 dimensions.
And so what happens
is you add now
an anti-Helmholtz-- or
quadrupold-- field in X and Y,
and this blue field is
done via the green bars,
by the Ioffe bars.
So you add together a harmonic
quadratic field in the Z
direction with the linear
quadrupoled field in X and Y.
And what matters
for the atoms is--
and what matters for
the Zeeman energy
is-- the absolute value
of the magnetic field.
So you add those
things in quadrature,
and because you add
it in quadrature,
you have now an harmonic
oscillator potential
in X, Y, and Z, so
you have an harmonic
trap in three directions.
However, if this field
is not larger than this--
if these field becomes
larger than this field,
so then when you add
it in quadrature,
you actually get a
linear potential.
So in other words, the
Ioffe-Pritchard trap
is quadratic for smaller
values of X and Y,
but if you go out
to large X and Y,
you get the linear potential.
So in the end-- and this
is maybe in response
to Matt's question--
for a high temperature,
the Ioffe-Pritchard
trap is actually not
harmonic in three dimensions.
It's linear in
two dimensions and
harmonic in the third dimension.
So, therefore the hit you
take in evaporative cooling
is not as large as
we'd initially assumed.
And the moment we
realized that, we
were building a
Ioffe-Pritchard trap.
And this has been
the traps we' have
been using at MIT ever since.
Well, just as a warning, this
is sort of the simplified
description, but if
you have curvature,
the curvature has to
fulfill Maxwell's equation.
And you cannot have a
curvature only along Z.
Maxwell's equations
are three-dimensional,
so you get sort of all
sorts of curvature terms.
If you really build
a magnetic trap,
you should understand those.
If you just want to understand
why magnetic traps work,
the previous slide
is sufficient.
The different ways
to build those traps,
this is the design
we invented at MIT.
It's called a clover-leaf trap.
So you have one
coil package here,
to another coil
package here, and what
you see is the pinch coils,
and when you have two of them
you create this
parabolic minimum.
We don't like Ioffe bars because
if you have a vacuum chamber
you either have to put the Ioffe
bars into the vector vacuum
chamber or you drill holes
through your vacuum chamber
to put the Ioffe
bars back and forth.
Don't laugh, some
people have done it.
Of course, they put
little tubes around it
so it was a very
highly-engineered vacuum
chamber where they could string
Ioffe bars through the chamber.
But we realized that the
same field as Ioffe bars
can be generated by
taking the Ioffe bars
and flipping them out, and
after flipping them out,
they had the shape
of clover leaves.
It's just a variant of creating
the same field geometry.
Yes, that's all I want to tell
you about magnetic trapping.
I think I should not start
with evaporative cooling.
This will just take
10 or 15 minutes,
but I'll do that on Monday.
So since we're on
time, do you have
any questions about
magnetic trapping?
Different forms of
OK.
Final announcement, next
week is the due date
for the term paper.
Yes, and the term paper
is due on the date
of the last class,
which is Friday.
Any questions about that?
OK.
Good.